[Music]
here's a plant and what you see here is
its shadow can you list the thinks that
the length of the shadow is dependent on
one its dependent on the position of the
source of light anything else that you
can think of if the height of the plant
grows then the shadows length will also
change right so the length of the shadow
is dependent on the position of the
source of light and the height of the
plant - so we could say that the length
of the shadow is a function of the
following two things the output is
dependent on these two things which
could be considered as the inputs that's
a very simple way to understand
functions could you think of more inputs
this output is dependent on here tell us
your answers in the comment section
below also how two functions work in
calculus that's what we will see in this
video previously we saw an idea to find
the instantaneous speed of an object
do you remember average speed and limits
let's say we want to find the speed at
this instant for this we find the
average speed of the car in small time
intervals near this position as we find
the average speeds here we see that
these speeds approach number which will
be the speed at this instant but let me
ask you a question how do we know for
sure that these two sequences approach
40 and not 40 point zero five or any
random number between these two numbers
we can find the average speeds at even
closer time intervals let's say we get
the average speed between these points
as 40 point zero zero one so forty point
zero five cannot be the answer but then
how do we know that 40.000 five is not
our answer how can we be so
and that it's 40 any solution for this
think about what information we need to
find the speed at an instant we should
know the distance travelled by the car
in various time intervals very close to
this instant let's say we knew that this
distance and time followed a nice
relationship like this one notice what
this relation tells us it gives us
information about the cars position at
each instant of time near this point
let's see how powerful this relation is
in figuring out the speed at this
instant from this relation we get that
at 20 seconds the distance traveled is
400 meters
now after H seconds the distance
travelled will be this so what will be
the average speed between these two
instances of time the distance traveled
will be this and the time duration will
be this and by doing some elementary
algebra we will get the average speed to
be 40 + H so now I guess you realize
what this relation has achieved for us H
here signify some duration of time after
T equal to 20 seconds as we consider
smaller values of H that means we are
calculating the average speed between
smaller and smaller time intervals then
we see that as H approaches zero the
average speed approaches the number 40
exactly if we want to find the average
speed between this position and the
positions before it we just have to
substitute negative H instead of H and
we would get the average speed as 40
minus H then again we would get that as
H tends to zero
the average speed approaches the number
40 so the speed at this instant is
exactly 40 meters per second is it
knowing such a relationship helpful
oh wait there's more let's say we want
to find the speed at an arbitrary
instant we denote this by variable t -
now instead of 20 we can substitute T -
everywhere here we get the average speed
as 2 times T - plus h then we will get
that speed at time T - to be 2 times T -
take a moment and go through these
calculations interesting right is this
formula correct we can verify it with
the results we got earlier at time T
equal to 20 seconds we get the
instantaneous speed as 2 times 20 which
is 40 in just one attempt we would know
the speed of the car at any instant but
this is all possible if we know this
relationship this is a mathematical
representation of a function we know
that when an object is in motion it
means its position changes with respect
to time so we have two variables time
and distance and they are related to
each other related to each value of the
variable T there is one value of the
variable D such a type of relation
between two variables is called a
function so the distance traveled by an
object is a function of the time elapsed
and how the two variables are literally
related is represented by an equation as
we saw earlier this equation tells us
one specific relation between the time
and the distance it's just an example
that we took if the car was traveling
with a different speed and acceleration
we will get different relationships but
now let's look at the beauty of this
concept the earlier found that according
to this relation at any instant T - the
car speed will be 2 times T -
let's see we slightly modify this
relation to this here K is a constant
now if we go back and do the
calculations we will get the speed at
any instant T - as k times 2t - in the
17th century Galileo discovered that
this relation is followed by any object
falling freely towards the ground so can
you tell me the speed of any object
falling towards the ground at any
instant of time that's correct
it will be equal to this we see that
knowing that an object moves according
to this relationship we can instantly
find its speed at any instant but wait
the story of this equation does not end
here let's continue this in the next
part
consider this square if we increase the
length of its site then we see that the
area of the square increases so the area
of the square is the function of the
length of its side can you tell me what
this function will be if L represents
the length of the square side and a
represents the area then the function
can be represented by this equation but
notice that this is the exact relation
we saw earlier we only have to take k
equal to 1 here so we saw two different
functions represented by the same
equation here X can be the time and y
the distance or X can be the length of
the square side and Y the area as we put
different values of X here we will get
different values of Y so X is called the
independent variable and Y is called the
dependent variable now whenever we talk
about functions to distinguish between
these two variables we denote a function
by a symbol like this so these two
functions can be
presented like this therefore we can
clearly tell which are the dependent
variables and which are the independent
ones we will see the advantage of this
notation as we further explore this
concept in our upcoming lessons earlier
we found out what the speed will be at
any instant for an object following this
relation we note that similar to the
distance traveled the speed of an object
also depends upon the time elapsed in
other words the speed is also a function
of time in this case we saw that the
speed of the object will follow this
relationship let's denote the speed by a
new variable s so we see that from this
function using the process of
differentiation we get a new function
but now what does the speed function
mean in the case of a square here the
speed is the rate of the change in the
distance traveled with respect to time
so here as the length of the square side
changes this function tells us the rate
of the change in the area with respect
to this length so it's the same thing
here that means once we know that the
function between two variables follows
this relation we instantly know the rate
this function tells the rate of the
change of the dependent variable with
respect to the independent variable so
until now we've seen what a function is
it's a relation between two variables
such that related to each value of
independent variable there is one value
of the dependent variable we also saw
how the concept of functions makes our
idea of finding the rate of change
powerful in the next lesson we will
further explore this concept but before
leaving let me ask you a question do you
think this example of a function we saw
here has anything to do with a
flashlight or a dish satellite
let's see if you can find this out share
your thoughts in the comment section
below and hey what's this we see on the
screen yes you can subscribe to our
channel by clicking here
[Music]
you